you
this its sky world news with Panar talat
the top stories Israel's Prime Minister
has warned the US President Barack Obama
that accepting a nuclear deal with Iran
could be a countdown to a potential
nuclear nightmare a fire which has
burned for three days around Cape Town's
Table Mountain has caused an explosion
at a lodge homes and a luxury hotel have
been destroyed along with almost seven
and a half thousand acres of land and
the families of the 298 people who died
when malaysia airlines flight mh17 was
shot down over eastern ukraine have been
allowed to view the planes wreckage for
the first time since rods prime minister
made a strong impassioned argument to
the US Congress not to support any plan
that could lead to Iran getting a
nuclear bomb further down the road let's
remind ourselves of what Benjamin
Netanyahu had to say would Iran be less
aggressive when sanctions are removed
and its economy is stronger if Iran is
gobbling up four countries right now
while it's under sanctions how many more
countries will Iran devour when
sanctions are lifted would Iran fund
less terrorism when it has mountains of
cash with which to fund more terrorism
why should I Iran's radical regime
change for the better when it can enjoy
the best of both worlds aggression
abroad prosperity at home Israel's
neighbors Iran's neighbors know that
Iran will become even more aggressive
and sponsor even more terrorism when its
economy is unshackled and it's been
given a clear path to the bomb and many
of these neighbors say they'll respond
by racing to get nuclear weapons of
their own so this deal won't change Iran
for the better it will only change the
Middle East for the worse a deal that's
supposed to prevent nuclear
proliferation would instead spark
nuclear arms race in the most dangerous
part of the planet this deal won't be a
farewell to arms it would be a farewell
to arms control and the Middle East
would soon be Chris caused by nuclear
tripwires
a region where small skirmishes can
trigger big Wars would turn into a
nuclear tinderbox I've come here today
to tell you we don't have to bet the
security of the world on the hope that
Iran will change for the better we don't
have to gamble with our future and with
our children's future we can insist that
restrictions on Iran's nuclear program
not be lifted for as long as Iran
continues its aggression in the region
and in the world so was it were that mr.
Netanyahu delivering his message to
Congress at the cost of alienating the
Obama administration we spoke to the
middle east analyst mayor java danfa
who's in Tel Aviv I think America as
American government may be less
sympathetic to the current Israeli
government and if Netanyahu wins the
elections again we will have at least
two more years of one of the worst
relations between Israeli guy sitting
Israeli government and a serving
American government and now that
Netanyahu has challenged Obama so overt
inside United States on the home turf of
President Obama President Obama may
decide to get even and we the citizens
of Israel could end up paying for it
when Netanyahu spoke some people gave
him standing ovation but some people sat
on their seats this is unprecedented for
this thing Israel and this is something
for us to worry about because Netanyahu
could end up doing what even exactly
wants to happen and that is to make
Israel a partisan issue in American
politics I think Prime Minister
Netanyahu's absolutely correct that Iran
must not be allowed to have a nuclear
weapon full stop everybody in Israel
supports that goal however it is way too
way
is going about it which is creating much
controversy and division in the State of
Israel he is dividing America whereas
before he was united it is support for
the State of Israel also sometimes he's
scaremongering here i'm using the bad
version but the Iranian regime is not
nazi germany and Netanyahu keeps using
this example getting a deal with Iran
that keeps Iran away from being able to
assemble a bomb within one year is
paramount that's the key timeline the
one-year breakout and I think so far
from what we've heard from president
obama that's what he's going for let's
see if the Iranians accepted but the
added bonus of a deal with Iran would be
that we would have inspectors on the
ground in Iran inspecting all the
nuclear sites and in all honesty they
would be doing the job or for Israel
because Israel wants to know what's
going on going on in Iran's enrichment
sites what's even more important and
this is the key issue we don't even know
if Iran is going to accept Obama's
current offer which the tamiya is so
worried about Iran could even turn
around say no what Obama's demanding
from us is too much and if you want us
say that by the end of March or by the
end of june that would mean that the
current trip to the United States by
lasagna and the cost which we've paid
for it in terms of our damaged relations
with America would have been for nothing